boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Saki and we
are still on site at Indy BIOS demo day
number 8 we are now talking with Paul
Schmitz Berger hello thanks for having
it on yeah super excited for this see
your blue playing ecosystems that's
right
that's right and you just gave the talks
on the main stage what were you pitching
well how you turn sunlight into seafood
that's what our company is doing and
unpack this more for us sunlight into
seafood yeah sure so basically what we
do is we replicate an aquatic ecosystem
right so we start by producing
microalgae in tubular photobioreactors
this microalgae is fed to zooplankton
what we displayed out there was a
species called Daphnia which is internal
natural food for fish and then for
shrimp okay and so let's start breaking
this down piece by piece so we said the
first one was microalgae exactly yeah
okay and yes so teach us about how do
you source microalgae where in your
growing I just did water in the first
chamber exactly so basically microalgae
supply about 50 percent of the world's
oxygen right it's quite a fascinating
organism that is the foundation of
almost any food chain in the define in
the world or at least in in water and
they are really really good in
transforming sunlight into biomass
they're really good if the conditions
are right they Takens you to break it
apart break water apart and recombine it
to beautiful molecules that you know as
you know fatty acids and proteins and
and all of that
all of that stuff this is what they are
evolved for and if you put them in the
right conditions their population just
explodes and because the phytoplankton
also are a massive contributor to the
oxygenation so if I'm saying
microwave sheets also phytoplankton
right so it is included in exactly oh my
crotch yeah
yeah interesting it's botanists argue
what is microwave if they even plants
its we are using this pretty
unscientific and mean both actually okay
okay and so then okay under the right
conditions so what are the conditions
for the microbiology so for the most
part its light as energy source
obviously but it's also carbon dioxide
co2 stuff that we actually want to get
rid of but also other compounds like
nitrogen phosphorus iron stuff like this
but in fairly low quantities actually
okay and then are you so then you have
to if this you're using LED lights then
is that no we are using yeah so we are
using sunlight are you some how do we
some height
I mean my background is a renewable
energy engineer right so if you're
working in photovoltaics for example a
lot of time and effort is put into place
how to align these photovoltaic panels
correctly so that the maximum amount of
Sun is transformed into kilowatt hours
of electricity now we tweak these tools
and mechanisms so we optimize it for
this biological process which basically
means breaking up this surface into many
many different tubes increasing the
surface where sunlight can interact with
the algae population and by therefore
optimizing the entire the entire system
and then you make how do you make the
sunlight just put our container so that
everything is interesting to us in this
outdoors yeah
it's everything that we do is optimized
for the outdoors okay
because some that is basically free yes
right electricity is not to them micro
algae is a living
in this top container yeah with sunlight
that it's okay except you have to add
the microalgae for when it's not an
obviously like the ocean when you have
your own okay okay and then because
let's we're looking at this container
you know we have the video embedded here
that we took earlier and that so then so
then you animal ecology then you add
then you have it sitting in sunlight and
then that's happening the first chamber
is what is the process happening the
first chamber how does it feed it to the
signature how does it move yeah fish
true so I mean if your views get the
video as well I think it's easier to
imagine so at the top which is exposed
to sunlight we grow these these
microalgae in these tubular structures
and then we feed it to the second unit
of the system and the second unit is
basically a large body of water where we
keep zooplankton in our case what you
see in the video and it's a species
called Daphnia which basically filter
feet on this algae and if they have the
same population characteristics off of
algae more or less right so if the
conditions are right their population
just completely explodes something that
we basically exploit right so we're
trying to create the conditions that are
ideal for these organisms and when they
are the number just increases
exponentially and that's exponential
increase happens with the microalgae in
the first one exciting and it happens
with the zooplankton in a second okay
and you know if you have exponential
functions in nature this can't go on
forever so what happens in nature is
basically that you have a bloom of algae
or an outbreak of zooplankton and they
take up all the resources and then the
populations just crashes this is what
happens in an algae bloom or if you
watch the newspaper frequently typically
in the warm summer months this happens
now we use computer vision and machine
learning to basically catch these trends
right so we are able to convert these
trends into actual data and feed it into
predictive models
to tell us when the ideal time for
harvesting the zooplankton actually
comes around and we don't just harvest
the zooplankton we actually switch on a
pump which basically thumps the the
Daphnia into the fish tank which is just
another large body of water where these
fish naturally feed on only zooplankton
whoa okay okay so got it microalgae the
zooplankton and the zooplankton are fed
to the fish
except Susan do you have to start with
fish population yourself and then okay
yes so this is what you actually have to
introduce at least every harvest once so
you introduce let's say 100 grams of
larvae of shrimp for example right tiny
tiny things okay but because they are
fed and treated right their body mass
just grows really really fast right so
out of two or hundred grams 200 gram
grams of larvae you get 1,000 pounds
2,000 pounds of actual fish 2,000 homes
of shrimp from a hundred grams of larva
yeah let's make make it 200 it's just a
very that's just a very tiny day that's
what's the fascinating thing with life
is gold and all you have to do every
time is only add the hundred to 200
grams of larva but then do you also have
to add any of the only in the first load
you have to add the microalgae and some
zoo play exactly so what we do as well I
mean you could keep this system running
indefinitely basically speaking right if
you harvest correctly and if you keep up
the system up and running then then
you're fine but we have many different
algae that that we know of right and
some have evolved to work best at the
temperature let's say 60 degrees and
apples work at temperatures of let's say
100 degrees so what what we are
proposing a
that during the wintertime you go four
strains of algae that are working best
under these winter conditions and if
summer rolls around you switch out this
algae that are adapted to this hotter
climates and the same thing can be done
with the zooplankton obviously as well
and to some extent at least for the fish
or shrimp ours oh okay and then now the
size right now is pretty large it kind
of like the size of like this discus
closet here yeah and where do you yeah
what do you see do you see the scooting
into like shipping containers and being
placed in like local communities and
feeding people that way yeah so I mean
our next step in addition actually is to
scale this up to 40-foot shipping
containers in size and the modularity of
the system allows us to basically scale
this up or scale its operations up to
football fields in size feeding cities
and even even countries if necessary so
it really becomes a question of scale
Stadium in size oh my gosh
yeah just that's mind-blowing I mean if
you if you watch the ships at Golden
Gate Park you know just rolling through
or not called Lands End Park oh oh yeah
oh yeah the big barges with all the
shipping exactly so they have 18,000
shipping containers on them and that's
our vision to at one one day load up a
ship like this with a farm out of the
box with our system and the cool thing
is that we can deploy them anywhere
right especially in in regions that are
currently not usable for anything else
like deserts and I think the interesting
thing is that if this works and we the
data shows that it actually does is that
you can take off pressure from either
agricultural space but more importantly
from rainforests for example that are
currently being cleared because we just
need to produce the soybeans to defeat a
growing population
okay so so in sew all the way up in size
to potentially football stadiums
shipping containers is the next step and
then also to be able to put it into
places that are either really dry that
land is not suitable for for harvest to
feed growing populations of people all
these types of things picture la la
geographically wises I think one of the
worst locations where you can put a city
with how many people 10 million exactly
it's basically a desert definitely if
you cross the mountains you're in the
Mojave Desert
so basically most of it has to be
shipped in from over hundred miles away
especially when it comes to fish even
despite the fact it's that it's on the
ocean but you have a lot of land that
could that's actually perfect for our
system you have a lot of land and a lot
of Sun and I think this is closing
closing quite a big gap and so many
people want to eat protein people want
to yeah and they want to eat seafood
that has never been exposed to micro
plastics and pesticides and stuff like
this so yeah that's I think I think we
are addressing yeah I don't think a
market niche in the beginning I think
you know going into this so I mean we
started this project as engineers right
about is because we like it but if you
go into the field how animal protein is
produced it's getting quite scary and
also for for the fishing fishing side of
things and I think here we can actually
what we can we have to look for
alternative sources and we hope that we
can be in such an alternative source and
then how does it work with I just have
to quickly say on the on the the micro
plastics and pesticides oh my gosh
that's a big point because we have a lot
of issues with our
or how we're polluting our our oceans
and and so that that's that's a big one
and so people as we do that cleanup
there we'd like to eat seafood yes now
I'm curious on on how does the the
couple questions how do the fish shrimp
in this case let's say how do they kind
of interplay with each other in such a
small like environment with a thousand
two thousand of them for shrimp it's
actually an issue because there they are
territorial territorial but it's not the
water volume that matters but the
surface stay Klingon right so even in in
a shipping containers size if you
introduce surfaces yeah you can do a lot
of stuff there so and compared with
traditional aquaculture our densities
are way WAY lower right it's we don't
even compare for settlement farming for
example you see stocking densities of
120 or hundred kilograms of fish per
cubic meter of water now a fish or a
harvesting or a fish that's ready to
harvest to put it like this weighs about
five kilograms so you have picture
twenty sevens this big in one cubic
minutes like the distance between us
right and you have 27 there so it's
actually quite disgusting and we have
stocking densities that way okay okay
it's called stocking density so yeah
exactly okay it's basically how much
fish you put into a given volume okay
and you have lower stocking densities
and also for some you're introducing
those like you said these barriers okay
there for them to cling on okay and then
and then one more thing is that you
talked about a I machine learning
earlier and I just want to make sure
people know so you're actually using
computer vision to
making identifiers on every single fish
to monitor it that's the dream I mean
right now be tracking behavior of the
swarm itself right so we are able to
identify every every fishes as fish or
much rather as the species were able to
track the behavior we're able to
identify whether a fish's sick or not
the same thing with with Daphnia right
we can track how active are they we can
count their population every I think
it's every 40 seconds or something so
it's actually quite dense net of of data
that we're collecting because the sensor
suite in this dense net of data that
gives you insights where you can
intervene if things are wrong exactly so
that's that's the reason why we do it
but not because we don't want to be
wrong or catch sickness as it happens we
want to turn it in into the positive
direction right so if a population is
doing particularly well we can see
what's going on there right to replicate
it exactly and then if you have like
this container farm right just basically
take this make a software update from
everything else and start the production
level from from this higher stage and
one thing that I wanted to mention as
well because he said it before I mean I
think for us it's it's important to work
with nature and not against it and these
ecosystems are already incredibly
efficient these organisms are incredibly
efficient so if you give them room to to
grow right they will do it anyways and
this is why things like stocking
densities and for us is really it's
really important to keep it you know
within ethical limitations yeah what you
just said there's massive to actually be
able to work with nature and stuff
against it yes so so big and we haven't
been doing this for the last thirty
years for sure or even
we yeah we haven't been working naturey
for so long our species has amnesia from
where we come from from what our sources
and we desperately need to connect back
to to nature and so yeah this is what we
are trying to do it is it looks like a
super engineered system and it is but
the engineering serves purpose to let
natural systems run the course if that
makes sense
right it's really building something
around the the core processes and if a
core process is undisturbed and runs
well then it makes economic profit as
well right yes yeah yeah so he's so cool
thinking about yeah the future of having
like blue playing ecosystems around the
world and so that the more people are
able to eat more local to them there's a
super closed-loop systems with with
microalgae zooplankton and and fish
being grown and seafood be going and
then just of the decreased transit
amount the more the less we're actually
stripping the oceans from I mean these
are like critical things the less micro
plastics that are in the fish that
consume yeah all these types of things
and I mean I just want to clarify that
that we don't want to replace like
fisheries and aquaculture I mean just
the fact that we need to double the
amount of calories that humanity is
producing in the next 20-30 years is a
concern so any technology that's able to
produce food somehow is is desperately
needed and I don't know if you saw this
cool film our planet or the planet okay
and then David Attenborough gave a
speech where he said and actually check
this out afterwards but our species and
our livestock is now 96% of mammal
biomass so all the
zebras and and lions and giraffes and
whatever that's an elephant's it's like
four percent and the rest is basically
us is like chickens pigs cows exactly
and then as humans and we need to double
this some how so how he can how we can
do this right and you've all know her
already talks about it - it's a it's one
of those big ones yeah
and they can I mean you can really go
both ways
so either we become like a monoculture
there so planets
and I'll really say it like this because
I think you know feeding humans is more
important than keeping jungles up to be
perfectly honest but I think the second
option is more attractive to have like
we can garden behind do we have to do a
garden planet yeah yeah they can't feed
humans and destroy our ecosystems that's
ridiculous because then there's no
ecosystems to live in afterwards exactly
and this this is my concern as well I
mean I think this the second option just
makes a lot more sense and I think
California as an example right you have
or in the United States you have mean
Europe being trashed a lot in Europe for
my mental stuff but I think what you
realize this is first nation ever I
think is the importance of national
parks and and especially you you oh yeah
thank goodness yeah national parks and I
mean especially California it's like it
shows how important policy is we would
have destroyed all the areas of national
parks yeah exactly yeah and now it's
like well yeah so grateful for that
foresight and it makes economic sense
right so I'm an engineer and economist
so I really try to see both sides but I
think sustainability makes economic
sense also in the short run I think I'm
so glad that you bring that up because
that's um we definitely would have a
much larger like dystopia if
we wouldn't take care of our national
parks along the way and we do need to
feed more people on the planet and we do
need to do it in a sustainable way Bupa
ecosystem definitely doing that well and
then what's the the close on the round
that you guys are closing what are you
guys looking for and also what teammates
and stuff do you need to get to the
shipping container size sure so we are
raising 2.8 million right now we got the
first commitments so fingers crossed
that our Andhra it's uh it's done pretty
pretty soon for us we want to use the
funds to actually build the full-scale
like full-scale stacks of the system and
we've got teams in place that are pretty
capable of doing this it's like
traditional Central European German
Austrian you know welding in labor and
stuff like this what we are looking for
are actually biologists data scientists
people that work between the interface
of electronics and and computer science
basic years okay cool
Wow I look forward to you know a future
where the kids can look back and say
that you know why didn't we have these
things earlier and we should have been
more connected to nature and taking
better care of it and and I think you
know blue playing ecosystems is a big
one this reminds me a lot actually of
like arrow farms and stuff to there in
the massive warehouses and you know yeah
yeah this is beautiful to see us moving
in this direction yeah I think all of
these companies are dressing the the
right problem there are obviously issues
with all technologies also like with
arrow farms where's the electricity
coming from and stuff like this but at
least they're addressing they are
absolutely addressing the right problem
and I think many other indie buyer
companies are addressing the right
problem just the fact that you have
investors that are saying cell-based
meets you know seven years of research
at least here you have money it's it's a
great thing and this is actually what
makes me quite optimistic yes yeah
huge thank you for coming on the show at
each muscle all thank you thanks very
much huge thank you how you doing great
work thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you'd love to hear
her thoughts in the comments below on
the episode also do check out the links
below to blue playing ecosystems well
check out the links below to indie bio
have more conversations of your friends
your families chorus people online on
social media about the sustainable
ecosystems and how they can impact your
oil teach to children spread it around
the world and I'll support the artists
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world do you believe it's sports
simulation our links are below so we can
continue doing things like coming to
India bio demo day go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thanks for tuning and we will see you
soon
peace